[Music]
many generations have felt they've
reached the pinnacle of technological
advancement yet look back 100 years and
the technologies we take for granted
today would seem like impossible magic
so will there be a point where we reach
an actual limit of technological
progress and if so are we anywhere near
that limit now half a century ago
Russian astronomer Nikolai Kardashev was
asking similar questions when he came up
with a way to measure technological
progress even when we have no idea
exactly what it might look like anything
we do in the future will require energy
so Kardashev scale classifies potential
civilizations whether alien
civilizations out there in the universe
or our own into three levels based on
energy consumption the tiny amount of
energy we currently consume pales next
to what we leave untapped a type one or
planetary civilization can access all
the energy resources of its home planet
in our case this is the 174,000
terawatts earth receives from the Sun we
currently only harness about 15
terrawatts of it mostly by burning solar
energy stored in fossil fuels to
approach becoming a type one
civilization we would need to capture
solar energy more directly and
efficiently by covering the planet with
solar panels based on the most
optimistic models we might get there
within just four centuries what would be
next well the earth only gets a sliver
of the sun's energy while the rest of
its 400 yata watts is wasted in dead
space but a type 2 or stellar
civilization would make the most of its
home stars energy instead of installing
solar panels around a planet a type two
civilization would install them directly
orbiting its star forming a theoretical
structure called a Dyson Sphere and the
third step a type three civilization
would harness all the energy of its home
gallic
but we can also think of progress in the
opposite way how small can we go to that
end british cosmologists john barrow
classified civilizations by the size of
objects they control that ranges from
mechanical structures at our own scale
to the building blocks of our own
biology down to unlocking atoms
themselves we've currently touched the
atomic level though our control remains
limited but we potentially could go much
smaller in the future to get a sense of
the extent to which that's true
the observable universe is twenty six
orders of magnitude larger than a human
body that means if you zoomed out by a
factor of ten twenty six times you'd be
at the scale of the universe but to
reach the minimum length scale known as
the Planck length you would need to zoom
in thirty-five times as physicist
Richard Feynman once said there's plenty
of room at the bottom instead of one or
the other it's likely that our
civilization will continue to develop
along bolt Kardashev and Barrow scales
precision on a smaller scale lets us use
energy more efficiently and unlocks new
energy sources like nuclear fusion or
even antimatter and this increased
energy lets us expand and build on a
larger scale a truly advanced
civilization then would harness both
stellar energy and subatomic
technologies but these predictions
weren't made just for us humans they
double as a possible means of detecting
intelligent life in the universe if we
find a Dyson Sphere
around a distant star that's a pretty
compelling sign of life or what if
instead of a structure that passively
soaked up all of a star's energy like a
plant an alien civilization built one
that actively sucked the energy out of
the star like a hummingbird frightening
Li enough we've observed super dense
celestial bodies about the size of a
planet that drain energy out of a much
bigger star it would be much too
premature to conclude that this is
evidence of life in the universe
there are also explanations for these
observations that don't involve alien
life-forms
but that doesn't stop us from asking
what if
Oh
[Music]